und zwar wenn ihr das hier in den tschad
schreibt / xp 500 millionen bekomme ich
einfach 500 millionen x3 de wieso habe
ich überhaupt diesen 3d modus und was
soll das denn jetzt schon wieder 3d
effektes wieder aus und damit herzlich
willkommen hier meine lieben freunde zu
einer weiteren folge der minecraft
commands es sieht wieder sehr schön aus
mit der sonne da am berg und blaudruck
ich finde ja immer es gibt so leute die
schreiben damit wirklich war die
kommentare es gibt keine folgen der
kontraste nicht sagt wie schön alles mit
shader aussieht das ist ein wirklich so
ich fand shader sonst mal richtig kannte
aber ich finde dieser schilder der
crusaders einfach perfekt da sieht sogar
dass die volltexte weltkinos ja herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft commands ich habe mir
wieder 3,1 rausgesucht heute sind die
commands ein tor wert erschaffen und wir
haben natural disasters und wir haben
dass man ganz ganz viel xp sich holen
kann ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr bis
zum ende dran bleibt dann das video
bewährte wenn ihr euer leben genießt
würde ich freue ich mich und dann fangen
wir auch schon an mit command nummer 1 2
ich hole mir hier natürlich wieder
erstmal einen command block und hier
noch eben einen redstone block dann
packe ich mal den command blog die
hinflüge dort diesen command ein es
ruckelt ganz kurz und die setzte dort im
redstone block neben und zwar ist dieser
command von unten im chat des denon
resource pack version und zwar gibt es
diesem tor von bender site wird dadurch
erschaffen und den gibt es einmal mit
einem resort pack dass man dafür
benötigt und einmal ohne ich habe
zugenommen ohne respekt weil ich habs
gerade schon mal aufgenommen
im resort pack dass man minecraft
irgendwie abgestürzt ich weiß nicht
woran es lag wahrscheinlich an meinem pc
video alles geklappt hat jedenfalls ist
diese maschine jetzt kreiert und da sind
gar keine sachen dran und keine können
von nix deswegen hab ich mir das hier
aufgeschrieben was man dafür benötigt
und zwar hole ich mir erstmal diese paar
items und mir die bestimmten sachen zu
kräften und dann hole ich mir noch die
rheinländer und zwar jetzt haben wir
diese verschiedenen sachen hier
und wenn ich jetzt diesen nenner sternen
aber hinschmeißen zusammen mit einem
stock zusammen mit dem amboss und
zusammen mit dem leder die schon bamm
bamm bamm hier ist eine axt erschaffen
worden
das ist nämlich thors hammer und zwar da
ich ja diesen resource habe sieht es
jetzt auch die sonne stinknormale axt
einfach allerdings eine besondere extras
zeige ich euch gleich
und wenn ich über die achse drüber
laufen kann ich dir halt nicht aufheben
weil ich nicht würdig benehmen therapie
ventures 2 gestartet wisst ihr was ich
meine mit nicht würdig und wenn ich dann
diese sachen hinschmeißen wie
beispielsweise das und das zusammen dass
und eine netter kreuzer zusammen und die
gold stiefel und einer quad zusammen
bekomme ich so eine eisen rüstung das
ist allerdings keine normale eine
rüstung sondern ihr seht schon hell mit
of torture speed of the dance off tor
und buchautor die kann ich mir jetzt die
einfach anziehen dann sehe ich so aus es
hat einfach eine rüstung an
ich glaub mir schlecht oder wieso habe
ich so ein komisches gesicht liegt das
irgendwie an dem helm hätte ich bin ich
krank und ich hab nichts verändert mit
meinem skin aber es sieht irgendwie so
aus als hätte ich weil sie nicht als
eher schlecht oder so also mir ist
gerade wirklich schlecht wird gerade ein
bisschen schlecht weil ich heute ist ja
nur eine pizza gegessen habe aber ich
dachte schon ich kann die kammer jetzt
nicht aufheben hab ich grad kamera oder
hummer gesagt ich weiß es nicht
jedenfalls mein skin der sieht irgendwie
schlecht aus der sicht müsste der
gleichkommen oder irgendwie so aber ist
ja auch egal jedenfalls das ist voll
schön hier so eine oase in der wüste und
so das ist ganz nah ich war es gibt
keine folge wo ich nicht sagen überhaupt
schön sieht es mit dem schneider ist
halt wirklich der fall jedenfalls denkt
euch jetzt was kann ich machen mit dem
hammer ich kann blitze erschaffen
diese sieht man wieder nicht letzter
wieso sieht man die plätze nicht nur
daran dass ich in der wüste bin und dort
keine blitze oder so nichts daran
tschuldigung habe ich aus versehen mal
alles angezündet jedenfalls ist dieser
auch das sieht auch schon wieder so
unfassbar tollhaus nennen die das
abwandern und somit den das ist
wundervoll ich weiß genau was ihr euch
fragt was kann die sache mal dennoch
außer so komische blitz erzielen die ich
irgendwie nicht sehe in meinem
einstellungen weil ich das
wahrscheinlich nicht richtig eingestellt
habe viel cooler ist sogar noch ich kann
diesen hammer einfach nämlich lassen
beispielsweise mal fallen und hier
explodiert einfach alles um mich rum mal
kurzfassung ich schmeiß den hammer
beispielsweise hierhin ich kann
natürlich auch weiter wegschmeißen
und dann
liegt der hammer jetzt irgendwo rum ich
weiß nicht genau wo er liegt und zwar
wenn ihr diese situation hat das ihr
nicht wisst wo der hammer liegt könnt
ihr einfach mieten und dann ich weiß
nicht wieso bei mir alles hier ist beim
zweiten mal klappt wohin im test teil
hat seit auch nicht geklappt mit dem ich
will nicht dass ihr alles anrennen man
jedenfalls kann ich diesen hammer ich
kann damit halt zu blitze erzeugen die
ich eben bin ich sehr und wenn ich den
wegschmeißt beispielsweise nach da
hinten steht schon da ist einmal was
passiert und ist hier jetzt auch noch
irgendwo was passiert gerade jedenfalls
schon der hammer liegt jetzt auf dem
boden und da ich jetzt geht's nicht
benannt der hammer da etwas angeht zu
nutzen der hammer kommt ihr zu mir hin
nach vorne brändle welchen baum ab und
ich kann als auch beispielsweise mal da
einfach den hammer hinschmeißen wo es
nur ging ich weiß mein englisch ist
kacke aber wieso ging das jetzt nicht
wieso wo ist der hammer möchtest du zu
mir zurückkommen liebe hammer wer das
eventuell in deinem interesse ja keine
ahnung ist noch ausbaufähig der command
wenn ihr es allerdings mal testen wollt
ihr findet die infos dazu in der
beschreibung dort ist der command
eingeblendet der erschaffer von command
& alles möglich was sie dazu wissen
müsst könnt ihr da einfach mal selbst
ausprobieren braucht dafür nichts außer
sonn command blog könnt ihr alles in
meine la minecraft machen während ich
hier meine welt jetzt jedoch weiter an
zünde ich weiß nicht der hammer kommt
nicht mehr zurück zu mir ich weiß nicht
warum aber wenn man einfach weiter mit
dem an nummer zwei was ist mit mir los
mein gesicht ist immer noch so richtig
grün als wäre ich einfach ich hab nichts
verändert beim skin ich habe nichts
verändert woran liegt das
wisst ihr wieso ich den den hammer
gerade nicht zurückbekommen habe ich war
die ganze zeit in diesem komischen modus
in diesem schiff modus ich habe außerdem
die falsche taste gedrückt aber naja wir
sind ja gerade bei dem zweiten command
schon angekommen und zwar habe ich mir
jetzt mal eben einen command locke
geholt und einen redstone blog den setzt
sich jetzt natürlich erst mal hin und
flügel dort diesen command einen der ist
nämlich von minecraft mein lieber freund
eine neue folge mit dir drin wie wäre es
auch sonst und jetzt wird ihr gerade mal
erst mal wieder so eine maschine
erschaffen dieser kommandos zusammen von
minecraft und arion gaming zusammen
erschaffen worden und wir sehen dass
maschine des maschine ist voll ism bild
wir klicken hier drauf um unsere items
zu bekommen und ihr wissen ich bekomme
einfach einen strack ziehen
hier steht natural disaster und daran
every year and natural disaster ever had
me your world this machine is active
manualsmania liestal dem desaster da wir
natürlich keine 15 minuten warten zeige
ich euch das ganze einfach mal indem ich
auf männer liegt darauf klicken und ihr
seht schon punktestand von bi für
konkreter so gesetzt und jetzt passiert
gerade mit mir ich druck geraten nichts
ich will einfach nur so komisch combo
und ihr seht schon hier vorne klappen so
dings ein und es ruckelt ein bisschen
unter com préval und das ist quasi so
ein erdbeben so ehrt spalt und alles
möglich wo bin ich denn jetzt sie ich
muss doch einfach mal hier erzählt macht
auch mir jetzt mal das ist doch das kann
auch wieder nicht sein was passiert hier
denn gerade jetzt jedermann lasst mich
doch mal ein paar jetzt hier raus bitte
also hier ist jetzt halt gerade so ein
erdbeben das gehört natürlich alles dazu
dass ich mal hoch geschleudert werden
alles so ein bisschen am rodeln ist es
muss natürlich so sein sonst kein
richtiges erdbeben feeling aber es kann
jetzt auch mal aufhören
das geht mir viel zu lange okay es hört
einfach nicht auf ich fliege jetzt
einfach mal weg also das ist jetzt quasi
das was passiert ist ihr seht immer noch
das ist alles ein bisschen ruckeln so
das ist einfach weil dieses die platten
halt so quasi verschieben und das ist
jetzt gerade passiert worden also das
war das eine disaster was wir jetzt mal
gespannt haben ich kann auch mal noch
mal eben eins machen das steht der
mieter punktestand von g für spieler
konkreter wurde auf 17 1950 setzt mal
schauen was jetzt passiert es gibt aber
noch so sachen wie ein feuerregen oder
lightning storm brought ringguth
da das mit dem blitzen bei mir gar nicht
geklappt wären wir wahrscheinlich jetzt
auch keinen lightning storm sehen denke
ich weiß auch nicht wieso dieses
erdbeben nicht mal stoppt alter das ist
schon richtig krass was hier alles
passiert ist allein wegen dieser kehrt
beben man alter was passiert denn hier
jetzt ist hier auch noch irgendwie so
ein regensturm gewitter oder so ich habe
gerade herausgefunden dass ich dieses
buch im springen öffnen kann wenn ich
jetzt auch fertig drücke künftig einfach
weiter guckt euch das mal an
ich falle die gruppen buch aufrufen die
nice einfach so mitten in der luft na ja
gut das ist auf jeden fall command
nummer zwei familien
schaut euch mal wie das aussieht so
richtig wie bei einem richtigen erdbeben
oder strom halt so überall so dunst und
nebel und rauch und alles mögliche
richtig krass also mit dem schädel ist
echt wundervoll schon das dritte mal
dass das gesagt habe das ist natural
disasters da kommt halt einfach ist das
ist ja kein command wo man richtig damit
interagieren kann sowie bei dem tor ding
sondern es kommt dann einfach alle 15
minuten irgend sowas in eure welt ihm
die sommergewitter oder so eine schüssel
und zerstört quasi ihr ganzes dasein
juhu ich bin draußen naja jedenfalls
command nummer drei ist eine recht
simple sache weil ich mir gedacht habe
die folge schon wieder recht lang jetzt
kommt ihr sowas etwas simples und blauen
block deswegen command nummer drei ist
eine mega einfache sache ihr könnt euch
damit nämlich ganz easy 500 millionen
punkte holen und zwar wenn ihr das hier
in den chat schreibt / xp 500 millionen
bekomme ich einfach 500 millionen xp
punkte das seht ihr schon 110 1558 das
ist mein level und auch wenn ich mich
jetzt beispielsweise töte einfach mal /
gelang gebe punktestand 500 millionen
das ist auf jeden fall richtig stark das
war es auch schon mit dieser commands
jetzt bin ich schon wieder eingefallen
und da jetzt auch gerade mitternacht
wird würde ich sagen wenn ich jetzt auch
mal die folge also command nummer drei
wirklich ganz ganz simpel sonst ich
hatte erst gedacht die man zum einst
anzunehmen nummer eins simple sache
jetzt hab ich halt mal angenommen goalie
bleibt man denn euch dieses video
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr mehr kommerz
habt wahrhaben wollte abonniert meinen
kanal weil ich gesehen habe dass bald
viele leute die diese videos immer
schauen so 70 prozent sind einfach keine
abonnenten eines kanals sowie können
auch einfach meinen kanal abonnieren
dann seid ihr immer auf meisten stammen
können wir druck enorm ich hab grad
gespuckt darüber würde ich mich sehr
freuen auch über eine bewertung und ich
schaue weiter in die weiten des ozeans
und ja wir uns mal wieder irgendwann
tschüss